an Amber Alert is in effect for a four
year old little girl in Texas after her
stepfather says that she was kidnapped
Melia Davis has not been seen since
Friday night her stepfather said that he
had pulled over to the side of a road
when two men attacked him and took her
Janet shamlian is in Houston with more
on this very strange story Janet a lot
of questions here good morning to you
good morning here at police headquarters
they are getting ready to resume the
search for Malia saying today they will
also be looking at surveillance video
and this morning we're now hearing from
her mother for the first time who says
she just wants her daughter home it's
like a nightmare it just just keeps
going and going
Brittany Bowen says she is distraught
over her daughter Malia's disappearance
what would you say to your daughter
right now the little girl's stepfather
Darian vents was the last to see her
Friday night telling police he was on
his way with Malia and her younger
brother to pick up Malia's mom from the
airport he says he pulled over thinking
he had a flat tire and was then
approached by two men in a blue Chevy
pickup similar to this one Houston
Police Sergeant mark Holbrook one of
them makes a comment saying that Malia
looks very nice looks very sweet the
other male hits Darren in the head vents
allegedly told police he was in and out
of consciousness at times in the back of
the suspects truck with the children he
says when he woke up about 20 hours
later on a highway
he had his young son in his arms but no
sign of Malia police are now looking for
the blue truck and the family's car a
2011 Nissan Altima it was spotted on
surveillance video Saturday afternoon
police say Malia had several brain
surgeries
the most recent just last month family
members are passing out flyers and
pleading for anyone with information to
come forward I have to be strong for her
I have to I have to believe that she's
okay I have to because that's the only
thing that's getting me through this
the group Texas Equusearch has joined
the effort to find Malia telling CBS
News they are hoping for the best
Houston police have not named her
stepfather or anyone else as a suspect
in this case John Janet thank you
disturbing story